طالبت منظمة الصحة العالمية
بإنهاء الهجمات الإسرائيلية على
المستشفيات ومرافق الرعاية الصحية في
غزة، لكن ليس هناك ما يشير إلى متى
ستخفف إسرائيل
هجومها العسكري الذي ترك
البنية التحتية الطبية في غزة على شفا الانهيار.
CN هو سواريز لديه تفاصيل ولكن أولا
تحذير  بعض الصور الواردة في تقريرها
مثيرة للقلق، رعب شديد داخل
مستشفى ناسا في جنوب قطاع غزة، ضربت ضربة مدفعية للتو
مكانًا ما في المبنى
مع انقطاع التيار الكهربائي، الناس في الداخل راش مع
المصابيح الكهربائية والهواتف المحمولة لمحاولة
العثور على مكان الضربة ومن الذي
أصيب هنا.  تم العثور
عليها ملفوفة في بطانية وهي جثة
دينينا أبو مسن البالغة من العمر 13 عامًا والتي
كانت تتعافى من بتر أحد أطرافها في
المستشفى بعد غارة سابقة
في هان يونيس وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة التي تسيطر عليها حماس في غزة،
وعثرت على بقايا أسلحة من قبل هيرد.  كانت
متوافقة مع قذيفة مضيئة إسرائيلية،
قال خبير أسلحة لشبكة
CNN إن شبكة CNN تواصلت مع الجيش الإسرائيلي، لكنها
لم تتلق
رداً بعد في الأراضي المدمرة
لمستشفى كامل عدوان في شمال
غزة، وداعاً مفجعاً آخر
لهذا المستشفى الذي كان تحت
حصار القوات الإسرائيلية لعدة أيام.  الذين
زعموا أنه كان يعمل
كمركز قيادة وسيطرة
لحماس، انسحبوا من كمال عدوان يوم
السبت قائلين في بيان نقلاً عن أن
نشاطهم في المنطقة قد
اكتمل ونشروا مقطع فيديو
لكمية صغيرة من الأسلحة التي عثروا عليها على ما يبدو
هناك وفقًا لمكتب الأمم المتحدة.  نقلاً عن
الشؤون الإنسانية، قامت
جرافة عسكرية إسرائيلية بتسوية خيام
عدد من
النازحين خارج المستشفى بالأرض مما أسفر عن مقتل وجرح
قائد في قيادة الأمم المتحدة، ولم يعلق جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي بعد على
هذا
الادعاء خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع، حيث
قال الرئيس إن نقلاً عن الهجمات على
يجب أن ينتهي العاملون الصحيون والمرضى في المستشفيات،
حيث تستمر المرافق الطبية ومن
بداخلها في تحمل وطأة
هذه
الحرب، وهو سواريز سي إن إن لندن